our next speaker julia dr julia penov is
the associate director at the tauber
bioinformatics bioinformatics research
center in university of haifa israel
at tauber
bioinformatics center julia together
with the tauber center team are working
to develop a bioinformatics platform for
analysis of omics data
the platform is constantly developed and
expanded to include state-of-the-art
algorithms and approaches for the
analysis of various types of omics data
including single still single cell
transcriptomics
spatial transcriptomics meta genomics
and whole genome sequencing along with a
whole bunch of other stuff julia it's a
pleasure to have you with us i'll let
you roll thank you
thank you very much let me just uh share
my screen
see how it is
and
let's see can you see my screen or also
my notes
[Music]
we can see your screen just fine
great
thank you
um
so um
just
get ready for this okay um so thank you
very much for the organizers elias
for this opportunity to speak today
and thank you to the audience for your
time and attention i hope
it will be
worth your time
i'm very excited to share with you some
of the improvements and the extensions
that we at tower bioinformatics center
together with the pine biotech have been
working on
for the last several months
today i will focus on the transcriptomic
section of the platform which includes
the
bulk rna-seq dedicated to analysis of
raw rna-seq reads all the way up to
differential expression and pathway
analysis
a separate section on the platform for
analysis of already pre-processed
expression tables which many times are
deposited to the ncbi database and so
can be
uploaded to the platform and analyzed
and the
post processing analysis of single cell
expression data
which can be either generated on the
platform or is provided by the 10x
genomics
or in the ncbi database
and also can be uploaded here to the
platform
so um
before going uh
into the uh
the extensions and the new developments
let me just remind all of us about the
basic steps
of the bulk rna-seq analysis so the
first step is the pre-processing of data
which includes the quality control
filtering out the adapter sequences from
the raw reads and filtering of the
duplicated reads which are mostly
generated at the pcr amplification step
of library preparation
and the next step is the alignment step
where the user needs to decide
which reference should be used it can be
either transcriptome
which are individual transcripts from
the genome annotation file
or the genome where it is possible to
identify newly spliced transcripts
specific to the dataset you are
analyzing and so
specific to the molecular events
which you are investigating
uh after the alignment on the reference
uh we need to uh quantify the expression
of genes or isoforms
and they can be presented either as raw
read counts which are recommended for
further downstream differential
expression algorithms
such as dsec2 or hr or others
or in normalized counts such as fpgam or
rpm
and finally the post-processing usually
includes differential analysis
some
pca analysis or enrichment analysis
and if you're familiar with a platform
then you know that we have two basic
sections to the platform or two basic
steps of the platform
the data upload section
where you are asked to about your data
whether you are uploading reads from
your own computer or from the ncbi
database
uh also the user is asked about the
reference uh whether this reference
genome can be found on our system for
example here you can see
that the genome is found in our system
already
or the user is asked to upload his own
reference
and
another
important uh step is
the experimental putting your samples
into experimental groups
so you are asked to drag the samples
into the correct groups so that
afterwards differential analysis can be
performed
on these
groups of samples
and the next part is the part where the
user is asked to choose the algorithms
and options
and again there are many different
algorithms and options for each step
and we try to help the user by
separating each step into uh different
uh columns of the platform and also for
co and also by color coding these steps
so pre-processing steps which are
optional so are missed in this pipeline
that you see on the screen
and they are color coded in blue when
pressed alignment algorithms are color
coded in pink and quantification of
expression is green and finally the
post-processing steps are orange
and when algorithms have been chosen and
the pipeline is executed
you can turn off your computer
uh
and um
because you will receive a notification
email when the pipeline is finished
and uh if you have seen and worked with
a pi with a platform you know that when
you uh when your pipeline is ready
uh you can download all your set all
your results from this download
folder
and if we look at this folder you will
see
many files
all of which might be important
but at first i think may feel
somewhat overwhelming
so what do we have in this file we have
fastqc reports which will tell us about
the quality of our reads
we have alignment statistic table which
will tell us about the number of reads
successfully aligned to the genome or
the transcriptome
we also have the expression tables raw
tables for our genes and isoforms and
normalized in fpgam tables
in addition we also have the dsep
normalized table with all the statistics
and the pca table and the pathway
enrichment
table
so
to make it more readable and to try to
help the user make order in the files we
now offer quick html graphs and
interactive dashboards
with most relevant graphs and tables
so
this is how now the
the pipeline ends with
links to the html graphs and with the
external dashboard
for example this first
graph this first link will lead you to a
graph
uh with uh wanting qc where you can
check the quality of your reads
and
decide whether the uh
the
pipeline that you chose
was appropriate for your data or whether
you have to clean your data a little
more than you thought was necessary
before
so the other html link will show you for
example volcano plot
and here also you can
decide and get a first impression of
your data and your analysis
and finally the last button will lead
you to an interactive dashboard
and the dashboard has
we think has two main functions at the
moment
first you can more deeply explore your
data and it is interactive
so you can
change the parameters on the dashboard
see what happens to your data when you
change the parameters so for example you
can change the thresholds of the volcano
plot or you can choose the
top differentially expressed genes and
see how they are expressed you can also
see your table and download your table
and
so this is one of the uses that we see
in this
dashboard and the second use that
we think can be useful for the users
is that you can also share your analysis
with your collaborators or other
interested individuals
the dashboard is no longer uh dependent
on the pipeline
and even if you if your collaborators
don't have access to your pipelines or
to the platform you can still share the
link with them and they can download all
the results all the graphs and all the
tables and they can explore your data
together with you
another
potential use of these
new developed dashboards is that
many times
maybe you have run into this problem you
are running actually not one or two
pipelines with the same data but you are
trying out many algorithms with
different parameters so for each data
set you might have 10 or 20
data set uh 10 or 20 um
pipelines
and
keeping track of all the uh
tables and of all your
graphs
can be quite a challenge so a dashboard
or collection of these dashboards
can also simplify things
uh and can make order for uh
for the analysis and for choosing uh the
for choosing the pipelines the
algorithms and the
parameters
so uh this was the dashboard for
differential gene expression and rna
[Music]
section and we also developed the same
similar dashboard for the single cell
uh rna-seq downstream analysis but
before going into the
results
let's just go over the basic steps of
the single cell rna seq analysis and
maybe some of the challenges that this
type of data
actually presents
so in single cell rnac uh
analysis pipeline we have three main
steps of analysis which are
pre-processing
uh integration of uh several samples
and downstream analysis
so let me present each step using one of
our projects
where we investigated the changes in
blood transcriptome in one of the marine
tunicate organisms
during hibernation
caused by drop in water temperatures
so we had five single cell rna-seq
expression tables generated from three
active colonies and two hibernating
colonies
so each
sample consists of
several thousand cells
and
is which are represented by about 18 000
genes
and the first step of analysis was
normalizing the gene expression across
all cells in each sample
and selecting variable features or genes
in each sample
and reducing the dimensions
of the
of each sample
using the pca approach
and the second step of analysis was
merging this different samples
together this is an important step
otherwise known as batch correction and
which was also actually mentioned by the
previous speaker
using
there are different algorithms uh of uh
[Music]
of this batch correction of
uh single cell data
so after correcting for the batch effect
we
cluster the cells and project them on
the two-dimensional plane trying to
sustain the local distances between
cells
and
for each cell cluster
we can find now genes differentiating
this cluster from other clusters
also known as marker genes
and
here in this particular
project we ran into some difficulty
and maybe some of you who are working
with single cell data and especially
with non-model organisms
can relate
and actually uh we found that
the
we found that only a small number of
genes that we found as microgenes
matched the known markers for tunicate
blood cells so we were
quite at a puzzle what to do with these
cells
and finally um
without much success in assigning a
particular name to the cell cluster or
uh we still continued with our analysis
and and we found genes that were
differentially expressed in active
colonies and in hibernating colonies so
so this is how the
actual analysis looked first we did
quality control and looking at the
graphs generated by the
by some of these
models that were by the pipeline
we can see that overall expression
levels or counts
in the hibernating colonies are lower
than the inactive colonies across all
cell types or all cell clusters
also the number of genes expressed in
each cluster is much lower in
hibernating colonies
and when we uh did when we performed
umap
looking at the umap uh projection
of cells in the manifold um
we can see that there are much less
cells in the hibernating colonies
compared to the active colonies you can
also produce
a graph that will show it maybe a little
bit
more clearly if you have many
cells so here's the number of cells
and the
clusters and you can see that the active
colonies have a lot of
cells almost in all
clusters
while the number of cells in the
hibernating colonies are very low you
can see here it's a 4 000 and here it's
just 75
and also the density
of expression per each cluster was very
low in the hibernating colonies with
some clusters such as
11 12 having no
cells from the hibernating colony
the next step was finding the marker
genes for each cluster and using these
markers together with
known markers of blood of tunicate blood
cells to assign a type of cell to each
cluster and again as i mentioned before
this was a major
problem actually for us
and
so for example we identified four good
marker genes for cluster eight
and these genes were highly expressed in
most cells of cluster 8 and were almost
not expressed in other clusters in other
cells in other clusters
however when we tried to compare these
genes to known markers of blood cells of
this tunicate and to its uh close
relatives we could not find any
uh genes that matched
uh
so in usual cases when you're working
with model organisms
uh there are different approaches
to finding the markers and to assigning
cell types
these use machine learning algorithms
and other single cell atlases that are
available for uh model organisms but for
uh non-model organisms this is a bit
more complicated and
sometimes is not possible
at least for now
so finally we could also uh find genes
expressed only in hibernating colonies
and almost not expressed at all in cells
of active colonies
so we found two of these genes
gene four two four eight and gene two
two zero one
so i think i made quite clear that
single cell rnac pipeline genera
generates many graphs and tables which
are all collected in a folder in the
result of the pipeline and we
tried to uh compress them each
model is compressed into its own
uh folder to make
a bit more orderly the result files
however still
we
came to realize that it is still quite
complicated to navigate all these
multiple files especially if you are
just starting your uh
your way into a single cell analysis
and so
we
have also a dashboard where all results
are are collected and are interactive
and where the users can
easily navigate through the graphs and
files changing
slightly the parameters
and we find that this dashboard can be a
huge advantage
uh it looks like unfortunately i don't
actually have enough time to go over the
dashboard but i'm sure we will uh be
able to
put this dashboard online and put the
video online how you can navigate
through the dashboard
and what you can actually see
uh
and again i want to uh just mention that
uh the dashboards can be shared after
the analysis is done
and when you have multiple uh pipelines
analyzing the same data set with
different algorithms and different
approaches you can collect these
dashboards
in a more orderly way
to remember and to come back to and
reanalyze
your data and share your research
with others
so uh
what we imagine for the future and for
the future we imagine that these
dashboards will gain momentum and will
prove to be an excellent instrument for
sharing biological data sets together
with the results for example we already
started some collections of data sets
related to the same topic
and which can become a resources
a resource for researchers
and where
each researcher can just
go
right into the analysis look at all the
graphs look at all the tables download
the tables download the code that comes
with the pipeline
and we believe uh
that these can really
allow researchers to easily navigate
all of the analysis of different models
for the disease for example
and
may allow
progress and quick interpretation of the
underlying
events molecular events
also we are planning to make these
dashboards uh
more encompassing including
adding the option to download data
together with all the code and r and
python so that even analysis not
performed on
on the po on the platform can be easily
uh performed
uh by the researcher himself
and
so we hope that the dashboard will
become valuable tools for our students
and researchers who use our platform
but also more wide community of
researchers who can easily access
these
dashboards these analysis and these
collections
of data
so um
i want to thank again everyone on the
tauber and the pine teams who were
instrumental in all the developments i
have been speaking about
uh pyotr myself
alexander
vadim sharov dr sofia fanatica dr lenny
brodsky professor hanov
thank you very much
and of course
thank you for your time and your
attention and
if i have i have three minutes so if
there are any any questions i'm ready to
take these
all right we've got a couple prepared
for you first of all thank you julie
that was very nice and thank you for
that
information what are the specific
challenges that are needed to be
considered when analyzing single cell
data
i think there are many different
challenges we don't make it easy on you
come on now
sure uh
there are um
many different challenges first of all
there are many different technologies of
generating this single cell data and i
think
one should be at least aware of these
technologies
and
use the algorithms that are appropriate
for the technology that you're using uh
another challenge is really uh
what we call batch effect so different
samples have to be aligned with each
other to be able to integrate them into
one analysis
uh and uh
another challenge is really uh
annotation of the cell types if we're
talking about
uh
some
static tissue and if we're talking about
time course then the challenges are even
more uh i think uh
hard to overcome
sounds like a whole other topic to talk
about exactly
we've got a lot of people learning here
so what are some of the different
techniques instruments uh analytical
techniques that you use to prepare a
scrna sequence data
so i think
basically the techniques can be divided
into two types there is uh
well this is a
you know
this is a very big topic actually when i
come to think about it and uh
uh really uh you know
to be able to answer it i would need
another 10 minutes so
okay
very good well we're about at a great
transition point anyhow so we really
appreciate all that data
and all of that information and we
really appreciate your time here and so
now that we know and heard more about
user-friendly solutions that make
bioinformatics more accessible i'm
excited to see how researchers and
students will utilize these methods in
fact if i'm right your the platform you
presented is already integrated into the
omixlogic portal is that correct
yes i believe it is
okay and that will allow students to
learn and apply these techniques so
julia again thank you so much for your
time and uh we appreciate your your
being here thank you very much thank you
for the time
[Music]